what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and last night we
finally got the first full-length
official trailer for spider-man no way
home and it did not disappoint now i
know some people of course wanted to see
toby mcguire and andrew garfield show up
proving that they are indeed in the film
however we did not get that but i'm
actually really happy that we did not
get that but at the same time we kind of
did because there were some editing
mistakes and it looks like we've
actually spotted andrew and possibly
toby as well in the trailer and it's now
gotten to the point to where i'm
wondering if they're doing all of this
on purpose for free promotion free
marketing which again would be pretty
genius but let's dive into this because
i know a lot of people are really really
going to like this and of course a
reminder that i am still doing my
spider-man figurine collectible giveaway
all you got to do to enter subscribe to
my channel and my buddy's channel cosmic
culture and leave some comments on some
recent videos so if you caught my
breakdown last night you should know
about the lizard scene and trust me
there are more scenes than just this
scene but let's talk about this real
quick because this is just huge and i'm
going to explain more than i did last
night if you did not catch this in the
brazilian trailer that was only released
on twitter very specific on top of the
statue of liberty where we see
spider-man going up against elektro the
sandman and lizard we see them jump at
each other spider-man jumps and the
lizard sandman and electro all jump
towards spider-man well actually electro
and the lizard kind of jump to the
opposite sides of him which is also a
thing i'll talk about in just a bit but
if you notice when the lizard jumps in
the air he gets punched out of nowhere
he's in the middle of the air and we see
his head just get hit and it goes back
to the left we can see tom holland
spider-man not touch him at all so it
wasn't him and he's not just turning his
head you can very clearly see that he is
getting hit here now some people are
claiming that it's one of the poles that
hit him but if you look really closely
and slow it down you can see that no
pole actually hits him there is a pole
behind him that looks like it's actually
going to hit him but then his face moves
way before the pole actually does plus
if you take a look at how his head goes
back you can clearly tell that he is
getting punched it looks like it's a
left hook or possibly a kick from the
left side it's a really high impact hit
so it's not him turning his head for
whatever reason that's off the table
that's not what's happening and a pole i
don't think would do that damage plus
again if you look closely no poles
actually hit him or at least cause this
initial jerk to the left what's actually
happening here is another spider-man
actually hit him he's just been edited
out of this frame we know that toby and
andrew are going to show up probably
within the last 30 minutes of the movie
and this scene is definitely towards the
end so this is probably a 3v3 fight the
three spider-man vs electro sandman and
the lizard and more evidence for this is
if you take a look at the direction that
the lizard and electro are going they're
not actually going towards tom hall and
spider-man but the other two aren't
electro is too high and he looks to be a
little bit to the right and then the
lizard is a little bit to the bottom and
to the left it's pretty clear that
they're not leaping to attack tom
holland's spider-man but they're
actually leaping to attack another
spider-man now more evidence for this
which i didn't talk about yesterday is
the fact that they're on the statue of
liberty and we can see the scaffolding
from the leaked pictures of andrew
garfield now i'm only showing these
pictures because they've just been out
there forever now but if we take a look
at the statue of liberty we see a bunch
of scaffolding on it and in this
particular scene where we see tom
holland i actually believe he is talking
to andrew garfield and toby maguire why
because the background is exactly the
same from the leaked photos we have a
couple of bars behind him and the ocean
in the background because we know this
takes place on the bay we now know it
takes place on top of the statue of
liberty which we didn't know before by
the scaffolding photos but this scene
right here with tom holland the
background is exactly the same as the
background for the leaked andrew
garfield and tobin maguire photos this
is a scene where they're all talking to
each other most likely before that fight
with the lizard electro and sandman or
after this is possibly the biggest
confirmation
right here a scene of tom in the exact
same place that the leaked photos of
andrew and toby are at that point it's
pretty hard to deny the evidence but
wait there's more we have more evidence
many eagle-eyed fans have spotted what
we believe to be andrew garfield's arm
in one of the scenes now it looks like
he's kind of been edited out but not
completely it looks pretty clear in the
scene where ned is trying to catch mj as
she's following that there is a
spider-man in the background it looks
like we can see one of their arms and it
literally looks like it's halfway edited
out like they edited most of it but got
lazy or got tired they're probably
working very very hard and working a lot
of hours and just didn't finish it and
somehow that slid under the bus but i am
actually hoping that it is andrew
garfield's arm because it looks like he
might have a chance to kind of get
redemption from that gwen stacy fall
perhaps he actually goes on to save mj
now the hand that we see going to catch
her does indeed look like tom holland's
hand and i have two theories about this
well three because the first one is just
a normal fact that tom holland is
actually going to save her the other
theory is it's actually andrew's hand
the entire time and he's the one that
saves her or it could be tom holland's
hand but he misses her but andrew sweeps
in and ends up saving her in the end now
i know some people might not like this
my buddy greg if the real rejects
pointed out that he would actually like
to see tom hall and spider-man save her
he'd like to see him do something and i
totally understand that but i personally
would really love to see andrew garfield
get a sort of redemption here by saving
mj now there's more evidence and it's
another scene that takes place once
again on the statue of liberty and i
stress this because i do believe that
this scene with the statue of liberty is
where all three spider-man do come
together i believe it's a big fight with
all of them many of you may have seen
this by now but it's a picture of
spider-man swinging through the
scaffolding of the statue of liberty
made to look like tom holland spider-man
but is it we could actually be looking
at toby mcguire spider-man or andrew
garfield spider-man in this picture
because it looks like somebody tried to
cover up the suit making it look like
tom holland's suit but forgot to edit
the eyes because the eyes do not look
like tom holland's spider-man eyes these
eyes are too big to be tom holland's
spider-man's eyes his eyes are smaller
than this but andrew garfield's and toby
maguire's eyes are much bigger these
actually look like they could be toby's
they replaced the entire suit but the
eyes perhaps maybe they thought people
wouldn't notice or perhaps maybe they
knew that we would but didn't care
anyways and wanted us to find out now
it's important to note that us marvel
fans aren't strangers to trailers being
edited to keep us surprised they did it
for infinity war they did it for end
game they've done it for other trailers
as well and it's actually kind of nice
in most cases unfortunately for sony and
spiderman no way home a lot of things
have leaked out otherwise normally most
things are kept pretty secretive at
marvel studios but remember the hulk and
wakanda that's the most infamous trailer
editing scene that we've had so far we
never got the hulk and infinity war we
got the hulkbuster but never the hulk
and we especially did not see the hulk
running with the rest of the avengers in
wakanda the trailer was edited and it
definitely looks like this trailer is
edited as well specifically because some
of the scenes involving the statue of
liberty and that scaffolding have toby
maguire and andrew garfield in it and
the studios made a decision to not show
them in the trailer and not even tease
them although they were kind of teased
doc ock said you're not peter but he did
say hello peter at first this of course
is because his peter parker is tobey
maguire's peter parker so therefore he
acknowledged tobey maguire's peter
parker in this scene there's literally
zero reasons for them to bring in the
villains and not bring in the other
spider-man especially since they are
referencing them i think after this and
after these very clear editing mistakes
there's very very little doubt in a lot
of people's heads that toby maguire and
andrew garfield aren't in the movie and
again the scene with tom holland the
background the scaffolding everything
it's exactly like the leaked photos to
me that's enough proof right there then
you add the lizard getting punched in
the face by a ghost you add the arm that
wasn't edited out and the tobey maguire
or andrew garfield eyes in this one
scene i think it's pretty safe to say
that they're in the film but let me know
what you think and also let me know if
you think they're doing this on purpose
because i kind of think they might be
but let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and of course for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you